so we had arrested a guy named Jeremy
Hammond and he hit himself he was a
hacker and he this would be arrested him
it's the second time he had been
arrested for for hacking uh he used Tor
um and so that kind of brought us to a
point
um the FBI has a computer system where
you look up things uh you know you look
up anything I could look up your name or
whatever if you're associated with my
case
and we were finding at the time a lot of
things in you look it up the case would
end be like oh this is tor it just
stopped like we didn't get any further
yeah so you know we had just had this
big arrest of uh Sabu and took down
Anonymous and and sometimes in the FBI
um the way it used the old school FBI
when you had a big case and you're
working seven days a week and 14 hours
15 hours a day
you sort of take a break the boss kind
of said yeah I'll see in a few months go
go get to know your family a little bit
you know and come back but
the group of guys I was with was like
let's find the next big Challenge and
that's when we were finding you know
case closed it was tour case closed it
was tour so said let's take a look at
touring let's see what we can do maybe
we'll take a different approach and Silk
Road was being looked at by other law
enforcement
um but it was taking like a drug
approach where I'm going to find a drug
buyer who got you know the drug sent to
them in the mail and let's arrest up
let's go up the chain but the buyers
didn't know their dealers they never met
them
and so you're taking a cyber security
approach yeah we said let's try to look
at this from a cyber approach and see if
we can uh gleam anything out of it so
I'm actually
indirectly connected oh to I'm I'm sure
I'm not admitting anything that's not
already on my FBI file oh I can already
tell you what you're going to tell me
though what's that the when you were at
College you wrote a paper and you're
connected to the person that started I'm
a [ __ ] you clever son of a [ __ ] I'm an
FBI agent or a former FB agent well how
would I not have done no but I could
have told you other stuff is what you
were about to tell me I was looking up
his name because I forgot it so one of
my advisors for my PhD was Rachel
greenstadt and she is married to Roger
dingondyne which is the co-founder of
the tour project and actually reached
out to him last night to do a hotel
podcast together I don't know these uh
no it was it was a good it was a good
party trick I mean it was just cool that
you know this and the timing of it it
was just like beautiful but um just the
Linger on the on the tour project
so we understand sator is this um black
box that people disappear in uh in terms
of like the when you're attracting
people
can you paint a picture of what tours
used in general other
it's like uh when you talk about Bitcoin
for example cryptocurrency especially
today much more people use it for legal
activity versus illegal activity what
about tour
Tor was originally invented by the U.S
Navy so that like spies inside countries
could talk to spies and no one could
find them there was no way of tracing
them and then they released that
information free to the world so Tor has
two different versions of not versions
two different ways it can be utilized uh
there's dot onion sites which is like a
normal website a.com but it's only found
within the tour browser you can only get
there if you know the whole address and
get there the other way tour is used is
to go through the internet and then come
out the other side if you want a
different IP address if you're trying to
hide your identity so if you were doing
like say cyber crime I would have the
victim game computer and I would trace
it back out to a tour relay and then
because you don't have an active
connection or what's called a circuit at
the time I wouldn't be able to trace it
back but even if you had an active
circuit I would have to go to each
machine physically at live and try to
rebuild that which is literally
impossible so what do you feel about Tor
ethically philosophically as a human
being on this world that uh spent quite
a few years of your life and still
trying to protect people
so part of my time in the FBI was
working on child exploitation Kitty porn
as they call it
um that really changed my life in a way
and so anything that helps facilitate
the exploitation of children
[ __ ] pisses me off and I I I and that
sort of jaded my opinion towards towards
tour because that because it it helps
facilitate those sites so this ideal of
Freedom that Russell for example
uh tried to embody is something that you
um don't connect with anymore because
of what you've seen that ideal being
used for
I mean the child exploitation is the
specific example for it you know and
it's easy for me to sit here and say
child exploit your child porn because no
one listening to this is ever going to
say that I'm wrong and that we should
allow child porn
um should because some people utilize it
in a bad way should it go away
um no I mean I'm a technologist I want
technology to move forward
um you know
people are going to do bad things and
they're going to use technology to help
them do bad things